okay they're gonna be typical all right
good evening everyone or good morning or
get a good afternoon whatever it is
wherever you are I actually can't see my
own streon but I can hear my voice
through the headphones so so I know you
can hear me so let me take this off so I
don't hear an echo okay yeah I don't
know how I can see my own stream I can't
see the comments right now I can't see
anything
let me give me a minute let me try to
figure that out
hold on a second I want to see your
comments while I'm streaming so let me
try to figure out how to find it I
haven't done this in a long time
it's been about two years since I've
done a live stream
I don't mean to keep you waiting I just
want to be able to see the comments this
doesn't seem the same as last time
YouTube has changed something I've got
to figure out the new way at least you
can see me and hear me if I can't figure
out how to how to see the actual stream
then I'll just do it and let you guys
listen and watch and just hope that
everything's going fine
okay okay I'm gonna try to watch it on
my own phone because that seems to be
the only way I can get access to my own
stream YouTube what are you doing why
are you playing with me so I'm actually
using my phone and searching for my own
channel so I can see my own screen at my
own stream this is getting weird
okay okay
now the wrong thumbnail is there it also
has the wrong thumbnail okay
now I can see my own stream and I can
see the comments on the screen okay
alright so I see someone from Brazil
what's up Brazil I see Holland let's see
so much that you are weird indeed you
are correct that is true Chu hey what's
up I know you will you'll be extremely
annoyed if I call it Chile
so it's chill a Czech Republic someone
said I'm getting old well what do you
expect five years have passed since the
start Afghanistan
cool Switzerland Germany Italy Egypt
India Brazil all right well I should get
started actually speaking to you guys
not just shouting out all the different
countries and getting that oriented
sorry it took me so long to just agree
how to actually sing the stream crazy
times the world is crazy right now
because of all the stuff that's going on
with the coronavirus and people under
lockdown I know a lot of you are stuck
at home and you can't go to work you
can't go to school or maybe you're doing
teleworking from home maybe you're doing
online classes for your university or
your high school or whatever so a lot of
people are stuck at home and just having
a hard time adjusting to this new
reality so I thought I'd talk a little
bit about that today and talk about how
you can sort of be happy and healthy
when you're stuck at home when you're
not used to that and then also how you
can use that time well you can use it
productively to learn or to improve
yourself from prove your life so let me
just let me get into it and start going
so about being happy and healthy at home
so I'm kind of used to staying at home a
lot because I do Lang focus I work on
lang focus for long hours at home I
don't work at Starbucks or in an office
or things like that I usually do it at
home so I'm kind of used to just being
at home a lot and I've had to learn how
to not go crazy and learn how to be
productive and just also feel good when
I'm at home so these are my thoughts on
how to be hot and happy and healthy at
home it's easy to get bored and it's
also easy to get depressed when you're
at home all the time when you're not
seeing anything new when you can't get
out of the house very much and for a
change of pace depression is very common
when people are stuck at home so some
things you can do one of the most
important things to do is to exercise by
the way these are all just you know this
might be obvious but these are just
things that I think they're important
and things that I try to do so I'm
encouraging other people to do them too
so exercise exercise is important not
just for like looking ripped and looking
good it's it's to maintain your physical
health and to maintain your
and that's a part of it that not
everyone really thinks about exercising
improves your mood gets your blood
flowing which helps you to feel better
and if you're getting depressed exercise
is a very good way to alleviate that
it's an important thing if you're stuck
at home a lot I've been exercising every
morning I normally do anyway but I made
sure to buy some exercise equipment and
get on top of exercising at home during
this semi lockdown period here in Japan
we're not fully under lockdown but we're
not supposed to go out that much and I
haven't been going out very much at all
only it's the supermarket really so you
can exercise at home with equipment or
without equipment I have some equipment
I have some dumbbells and I bought a
pull-up rack so I've been doing pull-ups
and chin-ups and and dips on the pull-up
rack and I've been doing push-ups and
sit-ups but you don't need equipment
there are a lot of things you can do
without equipment if you can do push-ups
and sit-ups you can do leg raises you
can do squats you can be squats while
you're holding something I hold
dumbbells when I do it
but some people hold cartons of milk or
they hold you know boxes or whatever you
can hold something to increase the
weight so it's more like you're doing
squats at the gym even though it's
probably not quite as heavy so the goal
is not to be jacked or ripped right it's
to get your blood flowing and increase
your heart rate so even if you don't
have the best equipment in the world
it's not like your gym at least you
still have you still have something and
you still have a chance to to get your
blood flowing and feel better so it's
really about being healthy both
physically and mentally okay it's
exercise that's one thing that I think
is important to keep doing even when
you're stuck at home the second thing is
strive to be productive don't just
consume but consume I mean like you just
take something in like you watch TV or
you you use social media or you listen
to music that's consuming but it's much
more it's much better for you if you are
productive if you produce
so yeah if you only consume
entertainment it's much easier to start
feeling a sense of despair because
you're basically sitting there passively
and you're not really taking control of
anything so especially in a situation
like this where we feel helpless and
like things are out of our control it's
much better to be productive because you
you feel like you're moving forward and
you are actually taking control and
moving forward in pressing beyond this
current situation so that's very good
for your your mental health and just
your mood in this sort of situation I
skip one line here social media can be
terrible for your mental health
so that's part of consumption these days
most people consume a lot of social
media and it's starting to replace TV a
little bit but social media is not very
good for our mental health in a lot of
ways I mean dealing with the comments
there's a lot of conflict in the
comments and a lot of people get angry
and it's it's easy to argue with people
and then you feel bad when you argue it
that kind of thing and then there's all
of the the comparisons you know
comparing yourself to other people and
how they portray their lives on social
media all of that stuff I mean when
you're stuck at home and you you
probably consume more of that then it's
even worse for your mental state so
avoid all of that consumption
consumption think about working on a
skill developing a skill because that
gives you that sense of mission and
progress
so maybe I'm stating the obvious but I'm
just sort of telling you my thoughts and
showing you that I care so one obvious
choice one obvious mission that you can
that you can take up is to learn a
language obviously you're all language
enthusiasts that's why you watch this
channel but it doesn't have to be
learning a language just do something
productive just so you feel happier and
feel that sense of satisfaction and
progress and you don't get depressed
when you're stuck at home okay so here
are some general ideas for how to be
productive and how to focus when you're
at home this is not only about
language-learning I'll get to some
specifics about languages later but
right now just in general how can you
stay focused and be productive at home
because it's not easy at first I work at
a university I teach during the semester
but I have long breaks this break that
I'm on now is normally three months so
the first month when I'm off it's
usually a big shock to my system and I
have to adjust and figure out how to
focus again when I'm at home for such a
long period of time so I'm kind of used
to this so here are my ideas on that so
the first idea is to have a specific
place that is your productive place so I
have this little office room right here
maybe let me get back so you can see I'm
on scene at 50 okay
let me go back for a second so I have
this little office room right here where
I use the computer for editing and for
doing research and stuff this is my
productive space so when I'm not being
productive when I'm using the computer
for something something fun over
consumption then I take the computer
into the other room I go sit at the
kitchen table or sit on the sofa
I try to divide those places into
productive and unproductive place I've
one particular place to be productive
when you do that you start to associate
that place with productivity so if you
use that place for unproductive
activities then you'll start to connect
that place with that unproductive stuff
so it'll be harder to get into the zone
and focus when you want to be productive
so have one place set aside for that for
me it's this room right here second
thing now this thing is something some
people are kind of cynical about which
is meditation now I don't mean like
spiritual or religious meditation not
like that what I mean is just the sort
of relaxation and breathing exercise to
calm down to relax your body and clear
your mind it clears the mind and it
prevents distraction if you're if you
want to work for a few hours and you
just spend like five minutes at the
beginning meditate
then it's much much easier just to get
started into focus and you don't have
all of these these random thoughts and
ideas popping into your head and if
they're there they're quiet and in the
background they're not that distracting
and you don't think about things like
I'm going to check your your smartphone
or you know all of the other things that
you you want to do later you don't think
about them as much if you spend 5 10 or
20 minutes meditating 20 minutes is a
bit hardcore but 10 minutes if you can
do that that's great or even 5 minutes
or just 2 or 3 minutes to start so what
I do to meditate is I just focus on my
breathing and I focus on a candle so let
me go back again and go back to the
scene
I have little candles like this in in my
productivity room in my little office
right here
I like this candle and I just stare at
the flame while I breathe slowly and
focus on my breathing that's it and
maybe my mind will drift off and think
about something else but when I noticed
my mind is drifting then I just bring my
attention back to the candle flame and
to my breathing so it's basically two
points of awareness my breath and the
candle so if I do that for about five
minutes and then it's sometimes 20 if
I'm doing it consistently then that
keeps me focused for hours at a time
then if I get distracted again later I
can pause and and meditate for a few
minutes again and just get my attention
back so I find it really good for
clearing the mind where were we okay
that was point number two another idea
is to put your phone in the other room
put your phone in the other room we have
an impulse to well let me backtrack that
for a minute most of us these days are
really addicted to our phones and we
always have this impulse to pick up the
phone and check our check our messages
or look at Instagram what we're really
doing is seeking stimulation because you
get that stimulation that dopamine hit
whenever you pick up your phone and you
you see something new your phones are
designed to be like that they're
designed to be addictive we're all kind
of addicted
them but if you put it in the other room
then it's out of reach and you're less
likely to pick it up because we have
that impulse to pick up the phone but we
have a different impulse to stay seated
where we are so if you're sitting down
you usually don't want to stand up you'd
rather just stay seated because it's
easier you're in that sort of passive
state sitting in your seat so you can
use that tendency of wanting to sit you
can use that to prevent yourself from
picking up your phone so it's put your
phone in the other room and you probably
won't go and pick it up and if you do
well it will probably be later than you
would have done it otherwise put your
phone in the other room it works I just
said that okay and if you do use your
phone for something productive for
example if you use the like on key an
SRS a language learning app or if you do
some kind of work using your phone then
avoid the junk try not to use Facebook
try not to use Instagram
avoid those as much as you can but then
again we're addicted so what can we do
if we're addicted and we can't help
ourselves
well there's a social media AK this is
what I do I load my timeline with
productive content so that even if I
open it I don't really waste time so for
me what that means is on Facebook for
example I only follow stuff that's in
different languages I read the news and
Indonesian or watch videos from CNN
Indonesia or you know I subscribe to TV
channels in Israel so I can watch TV
shows in Hebrew I get the news in French
so that's that's my whole timeline these
days so even if I I do open Facebook in
a moment of weakness then it's fine
because I'm actually doing something
productive so that's the social media
hack just prevent yourself from wasting
time looking at funny cat videos or
whatever by loading your timeline with
stuff that's useful for you okay another
idea this is an idea for procrastination
this is a mental hack for have to
mentally get over procrastination so
most people do useless things first and
put off their productive work for as
long as they can so switch those things
you could still do both but switch them
so what I mean
but let me go back to I'll show you my
myspace here again so most people
usually do the unproductive activities
first and then they do the productive
activities later they put those off as
long as possible I'll study later or you
know I'll do my work later keep putting
it off over and over and they do the fun
stuff first so switch those switch your
focus to to the productive stuff tell
yourself okay I'm gonna do this fun this
productive stuff right now the fun stuff
okay yeah I'll do it sometime I'll do
that later
not yet I'll just I'll do it sometime
not yet just keep putting it off the way
you would normally put off your work you
would normally put off your productive
activities switch that and put off the
fun stuff well the unproductive stuff
just do that sometime in the future
later and then keep telling yourself
that every time if you want to do it
tell yourself later later maybe tomorrow
or maybe tonight every time you have the
impulse to do it push that back into the
into the yeah push it off into the
future sorry it's late here and I'm kind
of tired so I'm getting off track a bit
okay right so switch the focus from the
unproductive activities to the
productive ones push the unproductive
ones off into the future as far as you
can keep pushing it back okay let me
find the slide work where I was I forgot
to slide them on social media
past that okay so switch them here we
are okay so those are some ideas for
productivity in general for how to stay
focused at home now for learning a
language at home specifically here are
some ideas people tell me well
can't go out and speak to people right
but now we have the internet so you
don't exactly need to you can do an
online language exchange and right now
lots of people are at home so they're
bored too they have you know lots of
time on their hands so it's probably
easier to find language partners at the
moment so if you actually look for some
you could probably find them you might
find some in the chat right now who
knows but if you join one of those sites
like I talkie as one where you can find
language exchange partners there are
apps like hello talk and that sort of
thing we can find language exchange
partners that's a good idea and then you
can jump on skype and you can actually
talk to them Skype or zoom or whatever
you use you can actually meet them and
speak to them online just like a real
language exchange partner that's one
idea
another thing is another thing you can
do is to take online lessons you can use
a site like I talking to book lessons on
Skype or whatever and then talk to them
on skype I talkie is usually it's not
always informal but the focus tends to
be on informal tutoring so it's a way to
get conversation practice and get some
feedback about your about the ways
you're speaking about your your skills
if you want to take more serious lessons
than there's stuff like lingo de or
there are language schools like there's
another one like lingua I think is
another one their online language
schools that actually provide courses
for you so that's another option if you
want something that's more laid out for
you but I usually use I talky unless
it's a language that I'm I'm just
beginning in so here are some ideas for
how to get started on your own using I
talky you're doing a language exchange
that's usually you know when you already
know a little bit of the language and
you want to apply what you you've been
studying to you get some conversation
practice but what if you're just
starting out what if you are bored at
home and you want to take up a new
language well here are some ideas to get
started different people do it
differently and maybe these aren't
revolutionary but these are some ideas
in case you don't know what
do so you can get started by listening
into the language a lot just getting
used to the sounds of the language you
can listen to YouTube videos you can
listen to podcasts by that I mean
podcasts in that native speakers that's
a good way to to get to get used to the
sounds of the language so that later on
you can imitate them
and be able to understand them because
you're learning to distinguish between
all the different sounds and after
you've done some of that you've gotten
used to the sound of the language then
you can use a course with audio so my
course I don't mean like apps there are
internet-based courses that are good I'm
sure I'm more familiar with the book and
audio courses that were that were big
when when I was younger because I got
used to those so you know I like courses
like teach yourself is OK I like lingua
phone the old lingo phone courses stuff
like that there are a lot of different
audio and book courses that are quite
good another one is living language it's
another one but work through the course
work through the book ends listen to the
audio a lot and also shadow the audio
I'm quite big on shadowing I think
that's a great way to learn how to
pronounce the language and also you're
also internalizing some of the sentence
patterns when you're shadowing them and
that sort of thing I've found shadowing
very helpful it's something I've been
really into the past couple of years and
you can supplement so you have that main
course and you work through it with the
book in the audio but you can also
supplement with other materials like a
pod 101 site or with lessons on YouTube
that are dedicated to learners of your
target language that kind of thing it's
always good to have some extra materials
just to for extra stimulation just to
make your learning journey more exciting
for you and you get all that extra
exposure to the language
there's always from a different angle or
maybe the topics are different and that
kind of thing it's always good to have
multiple sources and then you can speak
with people to apply it so that brings
us back to I talked to your
which exchanges so that's kind of for
beginners I guess for people who are you
know getting started but what if you're
more advanced there are a couple of
things a couple things you can do you
can consume content in that language
consume content that's a fancy way of
saying like you know listen to audio and
watch videos and that kind of thing
consume content just means that so you
can you can you know listen to podcasts
you can watch Netflix shows in your
target language you can read the news in
your target language that kind of thing
so that content that authentic content
becomes your textbook you can learn the
vocabulary you need to understand a
video or a news article or that show or
a novel if that's what you want to do
and then that becomes your textbook if
you focus on that content and you learn
whatever you need to learn in order to
understand that content oh wow I just
I'm just seeing I'm I'm looking off to
the sorry I'm distracted by my phone let
me go back to my office right here if
you're just tuning in I should let you
know that I can't really see what's
going on in the stream I can't see it on
the computer
so I had to open up my cell phone my
iPhone is right here on the side so if
you're sending if you're sending simpler
chats or whatever I might not see them
maybe I didn't see some of the earlier
ones but I see this one here at the
20-dollar one this is from VK he says
love your videos use them in my
introductory linguistics classes thank
you for what you do and thank you too
thank you very much VK I appreciate that
I appreciate the super chat and I
appreciate that you're sharing my videos
I'm really happy that you find them that
valuable the audio is low let me see
hold on a second did the audio just drop
out now did the audio just drop out now
or was it like was it low the whole time
what happened was my headphones were
really loud so I turned them off and
maybe that interfered with the
microphone the others fine okay good
good I just I see some comments off to
the side on my iPhone okay let me see I
think that was the last slide actually
oh I had one more so the content becomes
your textbook when you're dealing with
authentic content as your textbook but
you can also take part in the comments
that's one of the great things about
social media if you're using it for
productive purposes you can take part
and you can engage with people so if
there's an interesting news article you
can you can comment on it and you can
respond to other comments in the target
language and that becomes quite fun and
it's like a memorable experience it's
just like having a conversation with
someone in the target language it's more
memorable than studying in your textbook
because you're engaging with the real
person so that gives you that more
valuable more relevant memory that will
help you remember the language that you
use so it's really a good experience to
to take part in the comments if you have
no one to actually speak to face to face
okay so those are my ideas maybe their
their basic ideas there's nothing
revolutionary there but I just wanted to
share some ideas about what you can do
at home if you're you're stuck under
lockdown or semi lockdown or you are not
comfortable going out that much so it's
a time that we can use to be more
productive you know that it's not it's
not a good situation
but if I've been very least maybe we can
just make use of that time so that it's
not an entirely bad situation so let me
have a look at the comments and let's
see if there's anything more than then I
can respond to here I'm looking at them
on my phone and they they fly by rapidly
so I'll just try to catch a few comments
you're in there
Wow these are going fast okay I can
scroll back I can scroll back and see
the the earlier comments too that's good
so I don't lose them entirely I wish I
knew how to see the actual stream on the
computer on the PC screen because it's
much bigger and easier to find comments
someone says mate I love your videos and
you indeed I'd asked for what do you say
I'd asked you about a video of slow vac
do you anything about do you know
anything about it
slow back well I know it's a Slovak
language but I don't know a lot about it
specifically I'd have to look into it
Paul do you recommend native subtitles
for super beginners super beginners well
I have to think about that for a second
for super beginners subtitles so you
mean if you're watching a movie in
French should you turn on the French
subtitles if you're a complete beginner
yeah I think there's value in that but
it depends it depends I mean it because
sometimes there are very simple
conversations in TV shows and movies so
you might pick up on some basic readings
and just a few basic words here and
there you know good morning how are you
what are you doing things like that but
at the same time movies and TV shows
have a lot of language that's not very
natural it's it's sort of crafted to be
extra interesting so a lot of the things
they say are not really good examples of
how people actually speak so it can't be
good it's not bad
let me see repent everyone the wrath of
God is nearby cool lang focus you can
open a different tab with the stream
open yeah I tried that but let me let me
try it again let's see
someone asked what are the Kyushu
dialects like compared to the Osaka and
Tokyo dialects to be honest I don't know
that much about Kyushu dialects you I
haven't spent that much time in Kyushu
so I don't really know a lot about them
someone said Paul the microphone you're
using a side address you should speak
into the side of it for better audio
quality I believe there's a blue LED
lights LED on set side okay this is a
samsung meteor mic so I should speak
into the side there's a blue light on it
hmm to figure this out hmm
I'll look more into this for next time
now it's actually falling off the table
sorry I win the award for most
unprepared livestream today oh my god I
have no fun stuff to post on Facebook
okay well only serious stuff only
serious stuff well Facebook is a Meg mer
if you post only serious stuff for it
reads serious stuff I installed an apple
on Facebook that blocks the word Trump
because I saw nothing but people
fighting about Trump all the time and
that's a whole massive distraction I
don't want to think about hey Paul my
book cheers about toasting in 80 foreign
languages and about culture is being
published next spring Cheers
that sounds cool it's about toasting how
to toast in different languages an
interesting yeah once asked someone I
asked them how do you toast in Arabic
because I thought in predominantly
Muslim cultures maybe they don't
actually have a word for the toast
because they don't drink alcohol
or at least you know it's more
conservative people don't drink alcohol
someone told me they say to happen to be
there but I don't know if that's correct
or not so if someone knows please write
that in the comments I want to know
someone said what's your favorite place
in Japan my favorite place in Japan well
it's a two-part answer
I love Osaka because I've lived here for
a long time so it's basically my home
but I also love Tokyo because Tokyo is
oh we're back okay the camera died for a
second what's up with that
okay and the notice the notification was
in Japanese I guess that's geo-targeting
they know what country I'm in yeah Tokyo
is where all the actions at that's where
you know a lot of my good friends live
friends in both Osaka and Tokyo but
Tokyo is awesome because there's just so
much going on there inst a lot of people
there are doing cool stuff starting
businesses and working in jobs that most
of the international community in Osaka
are not working in most of the
international community in Osaka of
these Westerners they're teaching right
but in Tokyo you get people doing all
sorts of different work and yeah it can
be inspiring and interesting it's
exciting to meet people who are doing
something different so I like goes up
that's all right like Tokyo Osaka is
cool as well a lot of complimentary
comments thank you very much let me look
at the super chance again I'm not good
at keeping track of all this stuff the
DK I said thanks to him before
thanks again VK we have been say AK been
seac I don't how to pronounce that have
you ever thought of doing a video on old
English that'd be pretty interesting
anyway thanks for the great content you
put out this is one of the few channels
I always look forward to watching thank
you Ben I appreciate that yeah I have
thought about doing a video on old
English to be honest
about all of them I have a lot of topics
on my list that I intend to do it's just
hard to get to them because each video
takes so long to make and another $20
wow you guys are generous and I
appreciate these super chats thank you
so much for shark 12
you are amazing no I think you are
amazing for shark 12 and that's a cool
name the shark is roaring roar shark did
you donate twice did you send to $20
super chance or is that is that one with
two messages if you sent two of them
whoa
thank you anyway I really really
appreciated super chats I don't expect
to get them but that's really cool and
and okay 55 something what is that
Norwegian currency what is n okay I love
your channel and I've been a subscriber
for over five years I think I'm curious
how do you choose let me see that again
I lost it now I can't see it let me find
it again okay how do you choose what
language to learn and how do you start
oh well I don't really choose what
language to learn the language chooses
me it's all based on irrational
motivation if I was choosing logically
then I would have gone all in on Spanish
and really learned that we learned it
well so I would be able to make content
about Spanish which would be super
popular but instead I'm studying
Indonesian right now I'm trying to get
to a c1 level in Indonesian I'm probably
at a b2 level right now but I want to
get to see one Indonesian is a big
language a lot of people speak it spoken
by well if you include Malay then maybe
270 280 million people or something like
that so it's a widely spoken language
but it's not popular as a language to
study amongst people around the world I
think it will be in the future yeah I
just choose which language to study
based on
what grabs me there's no logic to it
there's a delay okay yeah there's kind
of there's some some delay I think my
computer is actually slowing down my
computer is getting overloaded so
there's a bit of a problem with a
problem with the sink hello from Greece
what have you studied are you a linguist
well I don't think of myself as a
professional linguist because I don't I
don't professionally spend my time
researching researching linguistics but
I do use linguistics in my job I teach
English as a foreign language from the
University I've done that for a long
time that's applied linguistics and it
involves a lot of elements of
linguistics but my dedication for
language is in general that's basically
just my passion I'm a language
enthusiast I just love languages and
linguistics and I have for a long time
so that's not really my profession it's
my passion
someone said are there any languages or
projects you started but couldn't finish
I don't know if you mean videos or just
languages that I tried to learn and
couldn't really get very far with them
yeah I mean they're big plenty plenty of
those plenty of both I've had to stop
some videos in the middle when I was
researching because it was too difficult
and I couldn't make sense of the topic
and I've started studying some languages
usually I was excited in the beginning
to start a language in these cases like
when I stopped early on I was excited in
the beginning to start studying this
particular language but once I got to
the difficult parts then I realized I
wasn't as motivated as I thought and it
was just more than novelty the idea of
learning that language was cool but I
wasn't
motivated enough to get through the
difficulty of it so that's where the
irrational motivation comes in if I
choose a language just based on logic
like this one would be useful you know I
never go very far with it I think it's
about time to end the stream you guys
because it's late here it's after
midnight and my neighbors can hear me
and they are start to bang with a broom
so it's time to go to bed but I hope
everyone stays healthy and keeps safe
out there wherever you are I know you
know America is having a lot of trouble
right now I know Italy is still in bad
condition a lot of Europe and you know
everywhere basically so I hope everyone
stays safe and healthy is as much as
possible and I also hope that you are
taking care of yourself at home trying
to stay stay positive and and healthy
and happy and productive when you're
stuck at home all right so thank you
very much everyone have a good night's
it's time to get some sleep but I'll see
you soon in the next video have a good
night and VK thanks again ovk said stay
safe can you donate it again crazy man
Wow
thank you so much I love you guys all
right good night